ni los expedientes de mar a lago ni la
toma del Capitolio el caso que más ha
comprometido a Donald Trump ha sido el
que involucra a la actriz porno stormy
Daniels y unos supuestos sobornos
pagados en 2016
el origen del problema se remonta a 2006
cuando la actriz y El Magnate
mantuvieron una relación sexual según
asegurado Daniels una versión desmentida
por Trump ella intentó vender la
historia de los medios de comunicación
primero en 2011 y luego en 2016 cuando
se convirtió en una amenaza para las
aspiraciones presidenciales del
republicano para silenciarla el Entonces
es abogado de Trump Michael cohen le
habría pagado 130 mil dólares Aunque
Trump afirmó que ese dinero era personal
y no de la campaña la justicia lo tomó
como un delito tras considerarlo un
gasto de campaña dado que podría haber
afectado su imagen como candidato sabía
usted sobre el pago de 130 mil dólares
hasta
Entonces por qué lo hizo Michael cohen
tienes que preguntarle a Michael cohen
Michael es mi abogado y tendrás que
preguntarle a Michael
cohen fue condenado en 2019 a 3 años de
prisión después de tildar de Injusto el
castigo y asegurar que sólo cumplió
órdenes de su jefe
Espero que cuando me reúna con mi
familia y mis amigos este país esté
libre de xenofobia injusticia y las
mentiras que dominan nuestro país
todavía hay mucho por decir espero con
ansias el día que pueda compartir la
verdad
el fiscal de Manhattan Alvin asumió el
cargo el primero de enero de 2022 y
reabrió el caso que había sido cerrado
por su predecesor cohen excarcelado en
2020 por la pandemia desempeñó un papel
trascendental para el avance de la causa
al testificar ante el gran Jurado
comienzo de 2023 contrario a las
especulaciones la imagen de Trump no se
ha visto afectada severamente incluso
sus fondos de campaña han sumado 4
millones de dólares tan solo en las 24
horas siguientes a que se diera a
conocer su imputación